When you look at the genomes of dogs -- a lot of dogs, you start to see a surprising pattern.
Domesticated dogs are split into two groups:
Asian and European
The question is -- are all the dogs descended
from the same ancestor
or were dogs domesticated twice? The answer is complicated.
Looking at the genes of modern dogs the world
over, at first it appears that they all descend
from wolves sometime before 14,000 years ago
in Asia
and swept into the West between 14,000 and
6,400 years ago.
But archeological evidence puts domesticated
dogs in Europe over 15,000 years ago,
That’s about 1000 years before this migration
happened.
This suggests that there was a separate domestication
event but the European dogs largely disappeared
when dogs moved in from Asia.
There may be some fragments of the western
domestication event in modern dogs,
but every dog alive today can trace most of its ancestry to Asia.